in that environment they are trying to
cast people that aren't going to melt in
front of I don't know a pitch panel
they're not going to melt when all of a
sudden you've got I don't know 15
cameras following around the camera crew
sound crew Runners all these different
people people looking after your kind of
personal affairs or whatever it might be
running around with you and in the back
of your mind you know that's going to be
televised they need to make sure people
can't melt at that point because if they
melt they can't make a program we need
to remember there's two different people
that are in tune at different occasions
you've got business people interview
what you want to do and what you can do
and how commercially Savvy you are and
you've got production people auditioning
you for TV if that makes sense